hey i'm kyra ham butch creator of Fairly
OddParents dandy fan on the tuff puppy
and Bunsen is a beast on nickelodeon and
today we're driving Studio Ghibli
characters from memory and be sure to
stick around at the end of the video to
find out how you can enter for a chance
to win this Wacom Intuos tablet courtesy
of our good friends at welcome there's
two free creative software downloads and
pistachios doesn't come with pistachios
it's the colors pistachio I think
everyone's gonna get mad at me I've
always seen a limited number of Miyazaki
films
I appreciate what he's done but I've
tremendously but the drawing things from
memories gonna be a little tricky for me
I love some more recent anime like one
punch man and stuff like that I also
love older anime like Speed Racer oh you
know I really don't want to get though
that witch from spirited away it was
like a thousand wrinkles on her face
yeah I want to get her the only one
who's not like an innocent woman yeah oh
my god I love Kiki's Delivery Service I
haven't seen this film since it came out
in the u.s. so like 90s yeah so Kevin's
oh you start trying oh he's like a bunch
of triangles
he's trying she's the old lady she's the
old lady
yeah she's like a big giant old lady a
huge head like kind of a like a bob like
a samurai yeah I remember seeing this
movie as well as movies where you hear
that it's like a classic and it's
amazing yeah and you watch it and it's
like oh my god like it's a classic it's
amazing you know yeah Jackie I'm nervous
for this because as you know I do not
draw in an anime style you really don't
the question is do I actually
to draw on an anime style or do I do my
own thing I think you should do your own
thing I feel like if you try to do it
enemy it might not turn out the best
heaven way there's one thing the
comments have told me Jackie is that
when I draw in my own way it ends up
looking like me from what I remember of
her she's kind of like she looks like an
ogre almost she's like a troll so mean
super wrinkly super detailed every time
I watched it I was kind of like amazed
that they had to redraw her said that
man that many times it's so hard I have
never seen this character I'm be very
honest with you I'm just kind of making
up an old lady what's like the animal
he's closest to is it like a teddy bear
like not even a raccoon
he's got whiskers yeah oh thanks for
telling me that
[Music]
does he have teeth at all yes yeah yeah
like when he opens his mouth to do that
he's got like a full set of like human
teeth I don't know if you can see Kiki
in your mind but her outfit is very
simple it's just she's just wearing a
dress yeah it's just a dress and she has
like props that you know right she has a
broom yeah and oh she has like a big
bone yeah
got it yes yep that's for all the people
who say I never help Kevin I help Kevin
all the time I help him cross the street
I help him get some sugar from his
neighbors I don't know what else old
people do you do help me check what is
you Baba wearing what does she wear like
a kimono thing she's wearing like um
it's kind of like one of those long old
lady dresses where it's like long
sleeves it's blue I have a ton of those
at my house yeah oh my god what's your
favorite Studio Ghibli film I honestly
really love spirited away really
yeah but also uh mm I really like Howl's
Moving Castle too my favorite Ghibli
movie is Princess Mononoke yes
nossek on the valley of the wind which I
think was very underrated yeah so what's
your favorite studio ghibli film am I
saying it right is it Ghibli or Ghibli
um
no I say studio ghibli I said Ghibli I
think you're valid okay
but my favorite Ghibli movies probably
spirited away angry I love that old near
and dear to my heart close second though
Porco Rosso really does she have a stick
or a weapon of any kind or a UH I don't
think so she has a lot of rings on her
fingers though she does yeah okay she
holds like an umbrella am i right oh
yeah that's a super iconic scene but one
more they were waiting for the cat bus
oh they're waiting oh yeah I don't have
them waiting for anything it's like a
big tail see I don't know ideas like a
tail but like every tail I give them
doesn't look right I gave them like a
like a bunny tail here's what I love
about Studio Ghibli movies not
everything is explained mm-hmm like
sometimes just like weird things happen
and they never explain it mm-hmm and I'm
like you know what I like that yeah who
needs the explanation yeah I feel it
leaning everything is a very Western
form of storytelling
that's very true Kevin I think about
this a lot when it comes to storytelling
are you patronizing me right no I'm not
I'm this is being for reals because I
think a lot of people's criticisms
against anime movies is that there's no
ending right but it doesn't have to have
it right because life doesn't have an
ending unless you die yeah I love the
feel of this tablet though this is
really cool yeah they're really nice I
don't know what they did to like the
glass on top but it feels a lot more
premium than like other tablets I've
drawn on its got like a texture to it it
feels like you're kind of drawing on a
more like natural surface like paper no
the first time I discovered I could make
a gradient on the background my life
changed that thing he's great right
no he's around right Turner of his
nothing he's got to be seen like
brownish gray oh my god what's happening
I was like not even confident and now I
don't know I wouldn't do that to you
I'm gonna hope that she has blue eyes
[Music]
okay I think it got his color needs like
a brown gray gray yeah I'm almost done
just get me away 30 seconds or it's like
30 more seconds 302 ah
did you just dab yeah who dabs anymore I
did I'm as done as I'll ever be
I think if I did not put those arrows on
his chest you wouldn't know it really
you know that was it yeah all Totoro is
some arrows his arrows on his chest and
the umbrella okay that's that's about
all I can do I think again like I always
say I think I got the gist of them down
but I definitely miss them are like how
do you think you did I think I did okay
you know I think it's cute I think for a
quick sketch it's pretty good I thought
I did terribly oh and I want to
apologize for all of you giveaway fans
out there I don't know if you guys can
see it but Kevin is tearing up right now
he's really about to cry oh oh my god oh
my god okay you were right he's great
very good very good teeth yeah I mean
talking about teeth your teeth in here
are very good yeah I want to see what
our tail situation is yeah I'm like a
rabbit tail I did I even like our rack
irritating yeah it's fine yours is great
yours is fine what do you mean you were
yeah I was expecting like the world's
worst drawing from the way you said it
like you drew like a scribble what the
heck that's what she looks like this is
incredible I wish she look like that oh
you're very kind
this is beautiful you did a nice job
what are you looks like this gosh she I
should it would help if I watch the
movie oh okay so yeah that's ease great
yeah he's good I think and we're I'm
gonna say something you got I mean you
put whiskers on him so I think your
character exist in his world though oh
thanks yeah okay but we both got like
different parts of him right yeah so you
got his tail cuz he's got like a stubby
tail yeah oh yeah this is so wrong
see accessories I couldn't I remember
the Rings I couldn't remember this jewel
you said bun on her head and she's got
like a like a like a dumpling on her
China dumpling that's what that is I
think I got the eye shadow you got that
right
yeah yeah I just drew a person nice oh
you know what we both forgot her big
orange bag
you sure did yeah she it's the delivery
service so what does she keep the things
in she's doing weird stuff and you know
what ours aren't delivering Jack yep I
think both of us drew her hair a little
too long I think so I think it's much
shorter than I remember I do I do
remember her radio I just didn't have
time to draw it in because he listens to
that radio in her broom yeah yeah on the
way back when Spotify didn't exist now
that I've seen the character and every
time I do this every time every time I
attempt to draw an anime type character
it always ends up more in my style than
the anime style so I've just got to keep
things in mind about anime for example
the shadows on the face there's tons of
highlights shadows varied anime
characters are extremely detailed I was
always got to remember that you made a
Greek character design be proud of
yourself very so to enter for a chance
to win this Wacom Intuos tablet all you
have to do is go to the BuzzFeed comics
Instagram account which is at comics
look for this post and follow the
instructions in the description best of
luck to you comes with pistachios you
know she listens to on her Spotify Kiki
do you love me
[Applause]
hey I'm Butch Hartman creator of The
Fairly OddParents and Danny Phantom and
a bunch of other Nickelodeon shows hey
I'm Kira and today we are going to be
drawing oh you don't know no no what are
we doing so today we're gonna be drawing
spongebob memes
know what from memory spongebob does not
cross my Facebook feed
yeah well you're gonna have a touch but
first be sure to stay tuned to the end
of the video to find out how you can
enter for a chance to win this Wacom
Intuos tablet wacka-wacka welcome for
all of your digital drawing needs
Wacka Wacka Wacka I know how to draw
sons drop characters but the memes I
again you know how to make sure there's
like a million of them a million memes I
know I know I tried to do you know what
meme actually means that means Butch
Hartman can't draw this since the club
means oh no I don't know which one that
one is is that the one where he's just
like it's just like open mouth uh-huh
all right handsome Squidward okay
okay this is the one I pretty sure I can
do what is I talked about it in an older
episode wait how can you explain this to
me he's a huge mush I know Squidward -
laughs beautiful he's like what he
wishes he could be guy let me break it
down for you
so he's like a cave and spongebob he's
got like a pace right okay a face a face
yes okay he's got like a little
loincloth loincloth link lie and he's
like shocked
so he's like wow like that he's got like
his mouth kind of off to the side and
he's like okay I got it
maybe do I do you want me to stand here
the whole time and he looks like a man
more than a octa was squid for today a
day as we would face sort of he's got
like she's like a man wearing a way to
word like body paint home okay got it
got it okay okay very hands I think I
got this
he said not having it at all one thing
very distinct about hansoms good word he
has squinted closed eyes and very pursed
lips hmm like I like the like the
smolder yes have you actually seen this
mean before I I think I know what it is
right I've seen it before and I don't
really pay attention to means so this is
a universal mean I would say Dennis so
it's a smaller nose yeah
same nose but smaller same nose but
smaller he's handsome Squidward
how many fingers does spongebob have
again or okay he's a four fingered kur
kids
I wonder why spongebob is the thing that
gets me methide so much I mean they're
very funny drawings but it's like so
much so many episodes right yeah there's
like so much to pull from is a lot to
draw on I guess what is he what is he
looking at when he's doing this he's
kind of just like staring off into the
void into the boy Jason I am here for
you for whatever you need I will be your
meme spirit guide I don't know how big
his eyes are yeah when you're drawing
people surprise they're either have
really big eyes or really small eyes I'm
like a Luke like it doesn't quite look
like what I'm imagining you know what
kids someone ever tells you memes are
easy
you tell him well Jackie said they're
not things are hard memes are really
hard actually no I think I do something
I do like a surfing hi spongebob
write something hi bundle you know what
actually looking at mine I think that is
kind of what he is which well you're at
Nickelodeon did you get to meet or hang
out with any of the Spongebob crew
absolutely I met them of course and then
worked around them every day oh the
environment in those days was very
interesting because we all knew each
other we saw each other but everybody
was so focused on making their shows all
day we were kind of just in our little
nest doing our work but occasionally
they have you know they have office
parties and get-togethers and events and
things we'd see each other they were the
nicest guys you know Vince Waller is a
very good friend of mine very sweet guy
and super talented artist Steve
Hillenburg I knew him pretty good didn't
know him as well as I wanted to he was a
very quiet guy but the nicest guy in the
world
I knew him for like yeah about 20 years
mine's going good so far
I made the mouth a little bigger because
you made me really I'm going huge with
them mouth I just I feel like I feel
like that's the whole mean it's just
like it's just a mouth yeah he's very
surprised I may have screwed up his feet
how could you do that I think I may have
given him more feet than he actually has
what does that mean what how did you do
that what does that mean no no no no no
does he have like
are good here yes no I don't know you
know you should give it like I love
these details you're adding though and I
think you should go for it because you
have like pimples well no because he's
already got holes Oh true true I'm not
deleting that some ships have sailed
already it's wrong let me ask you this
have you watched my youtube channel I
have not I need to what is it it has a
super creative name are you ready yes
it's called Butch Hartman fantastic I do
a lot of stuff about artwork and
cartoons it's entertainment based like
you know if a new Marvel movie comes out
I'll draw like Marvel characters in The
Fairly OddParents style I did a bunch of
Danny Phantom ten years later videos
with Danny Phantom is very popular
character that's awesome people love
seeing artists you know really explain
their process and communicate with
people I actually really liked when I'm
drawing that's what's important this
could be the birth of a new spongebob
meme that would be dope
how many choices we have I am like three
did he have like hair on the top of his
feet you know I like some yeah I'm here
on the top of his feet I don't think he
does
but I think he look you whatever on his
feet it's funny I now when I think of
Patrick I see your drawing straw in my
head this is like extra super
challenging though because not only do
you have to draw this character you have
to draw him in a very specific pose yeah
how you doing Kevin I'm almost done
you're almost done how are you doing I'm
doing pretty good I'm like just I'm
nitpicking now sorry
he's adding some shading in here now
quite sure I know that this from wrong
to but oh well he does look like he's
like tripping balls yeah okay good
you know what I think it'll capture the
spirit of him yeah nothing else all
right you good I am done all right
let's stop that all set yeah I think I
did all right I mean the expression
isn't like exactly right Jason how do
you think you did you know I think I
followed directions I did not get a face
yeah because I was trying to draw
spongebob
first so maybe this is actually a test
on my teaching abilities explain well I
do something that looks like a Squidward
type of character could be related to
him I want to see what she thinks she is
the judge so I leave it up to you here
be the judge of mine all right how do
you think you did I have no idea I feel
like I'm remembering something different
but you know I think it's funny maybe
this can be the new meme I think I did
okay I think it's surprising that I
remember this meme better than you do I
think it's surprising as well yeah
mm-hmm all right let's do it
let's switcheroo ah I understand the
excess of feet now right very nice okay
this is really good okay I like that now
I think I have seen this yes oh my god
looks like spongebob meets Homer Simpson
oh man description I think less than an
excess of feet it feels like you gave
him shoes I gave him the wrong feet you
gave him in wrong feet you didn't give
him too many his feet are just numbers
they're just nubs
he's a starfish you don't got his lips
they're perfect I love it he kind of
looks like an actor but I can't really
place her so you gave him walleyes yeah
I don't know
I thought the walleyes felt right yeah
my brain and you also gave him small
eyes yeah you gave him small eyes and
walleyes walleye small eyes am i right
ladies
yep no dad once again Butch Hartman
reality hit switch Hartman in the face
oh I did oh well okay was the neck up
there you got it close yours is like
really close much you know this looks
like in the twilight zone years ago the
show to serve man looks like the alien
from the serve man no no no that's what
that is oh boy
Oh
Wow Wow the only thing easy to do is the
cheaper like Oh No
oh yeah he's got like tusks teeth this
is spot on friend what about Jason's
paper I think you did better than I did
really yeah I think I think I think if
we combined our drawings they would be
perfect right mouth is not not as big
not as big I led you astray Jeff you led
me astray after all the help I gave you
with the other episodes I just the thing
that I remember most about the meme is
that his his mouth is a gaping huge it
is it is huge you know what I did like I
did add the thing that the parabola to
the little dangly of dangly Wang in the
back of the mouth Wow it's the best
Patrick you've done thank you you've
only drawn two and this one takes the
cake
thank you this is also an excellent
Patrick once again not super accurate
but very Jackie okay giveaway time if
you want to enter for a chance to win
this Wacom Intuos tablet all you have to
do is go to the BuzzFeed comics
Instagram that's at comics on Instagram
and find this post and follow the
instructions in the description best of
luck to you digital painting photo
editing comic and manga you don't have
to be accurate with everything in life
that's literally what we're doing on the
show if you throw a potato at someone
and you miss their head but you hit
their chest it's still gonna really hurt
them so where do you get these metaphors
I am Kira damned Butch Hartman I've
created some shows at Nickelodeon that
are animated what are we doing today
today we are drawing Nicktoons from this
will be fun cuz I don't know what era
Nicktoons yeah thousands era 90s era 900
era I have a chance but first be sure to
stick around till the end of the video
to find out how you can enter for a
chance to win this walk them into a
tablet experience experiment for a
creativity
damn money Rin Novant Jackie will not be
their new spokesperson Bonjour are you
ready Jackie I'm ready are you are you
good with the Nicktoons I did watch my
nicktoons you know okay I watched a lot
more of it the older I got your
character today is Doug Doug funnie now
Doug I've seen I've actually seen done
wait wait wait Wren was the Chihuahua
Stimpy was the cat all right yeah yeah
yeah wait friend no Ren's of the cat
Stimpy's the Chihuahua
I think Stimpy whole oh boy which one
are we drawing a cat day we're drawing
right all right Stan we're running
sniffy what wait pressures on because as
you know Butch Hartman is here to
ridicule and mock us for our drawing so
we better be good someone better be good
yeah there we go
yeah if it was a cat okay so he's just
like a big round and he's red right yeah
isn't he wearing gloves wrong I don't
yes I think he is here's the thing about
Ren & Stimpy - so they actually go off
model a lot yes so there's not really
like one very like canonical like form
that they take so this is not a style
that I usually draw in it's very angular
it's very much in the UPA style with UPA
u-v-a stands for Universal productions
of America they were a popular
production company in the 50s and 60s
responsible for a lot of kind of angular
styles that you see and like Dexter's
Laboratory and stuff like that I see
well you think your biggest inspiration
was it changed a lot I think like as a
kid really loved you know like pokemon
digimon that sort of suit anime style
mm-hmm and then got more into cartoons
that I got more into like the UPA
hanna-barbera think I was
oh my god I feel like a child again
drawing this yeah like just struggling
to draw like your favorite characters
don't forget them very related items
okay yeah I remember I mean obviously
she has wings mm-hmm well there's
another thing you can't forget it what
is it they always have it coming their
wands there's another thing Kevin oh my
God why figure it out why did nine eight
seven six five four three little don't
know their crowns Oh crowns creaked him
out you did freak me I would have
forgotten the crown thank you for
telling you're welcome what is the
origin story behind Fairly OddParents
thank you for asking I was at Cartoon
Network at the time around the Johnny
Bravo show and that show was about to
end and I was gonna lose my job and you
know you have to pay the bills and
that's like well I need a job but I was
tired of working for other people and so
finally I said I'm gonna make my own
show so I literally sat down and I said
what if I was gonna make a show of
anything what would I make I thought
well I'll make a show about a little boy
we always write or draw what we know
right I drew this little kid I decided
to call him Timmy cuz I've got a brother
named Timmy oh I also have a brother
named Mike I was gonna have my brother
Michael we had a fight that day you lost
your chance man no Mike's a great guy
but so anyway I came with the show with
Timmy and I'm like what can I do with
him no that's that way it'd be cool to
give him like a way to get around
quickly I felt like a teleport him like
you know science stuff but I couldn't do
science stuff because Dexter's Lab was
already out and so I decided well I
could use I could make magic so I
thought well I can give the kid magic
powers or give them that magic friend so
I gave him Wanda I drew Wanda first I
thought okay he's got a magic fairy
godmother like Cinderella I call that
boys versus Cinderella that'll be fun
I've never seen a fairy godfather before
so I drew Cosmo and all of this took
about 15 minutes really that's kind of
cool yeah it's kind of went from there
oh this is a sad a sad day for Jason and
Bryn straw furrier yeah yeah I don't
think I really captured his personality
much like this is like some mischievous
gremlin
you know what I don't know Wanda's
colors you don't know Cosmo and Wanda's
colors they're very I mean I mean I know
that Wanda is a redhead
right Oh redhead right oh this episode's
going downhill oh no no no no come on
you have to tell me am i right is she a
redhead
what inferior edit you know what I'm
making her a redhead I'm committing to
it right Kyra how you doing over there
think pretty good trying to remember his
outfit you know as much as I'm
struggling I think this looks like him
oh okay
I think you could look at this and go oh
yeah that's Stimpy I think exactly what
that inflection is what someone would
say if these new monitors are cuz it
gives me so much space these monitors
make me feel like a king it makes me
feel like I'm drawing for the Queen oh
no this doesn't look right
oh I thought I was doing well and now
just at the end up stumbling the color I
screwing up the color Jackie helped me
well what are you doing wrong is she a
redhead no Kevin what a shot of redhead
Cosmo is green what looks good with
green red orange Jackie helped me go
down the color line come on pink yeah
she has pink hair yes big ones as done
as I'll ever want it to be okay I'm done
I think I can't I can't possibly put any
more dug in here and I been putting my
pen down alright Jackie how'd you do I
don't think it looks on model mmm
as much as I wanted it to I thought I
could do better than this honestly but
still I think it's not too far off did
okay I think maybe this is a close
representation of Doug it's like Doug's
cousin if I had to grade my performance
today
I would say solid c-minus not employable
at Nickelodeon at this time
I've already grade my performance I'd
give it a D oh man you're more harsh
grater yeah I don't know why I thought
I'd pass I think I'm a DJ I think I
stumbled with the color but I think I
got the general construction I think I
got the face okay we'll see okay I'm
ready switchy ties switchy
hey hey hey nice oh yeah he's gonna go
watch fairly often
that's really about like his pose thank
you I love you rious brown pants doesn't
he
oh wait okay you I got him this is
basically him right this is so far off I
love whoever this is I love yours thanks
it's exactly what you said it's not on
model but it is very cute I like yours I
like that your wand isn't even complete
like you thought it was like a
magician's right it's always like
sparkly at the end it's got a star
though no boy oh boy it looks like Wanda
it's just the little things that are
wrong this dippy is a great addition to
the draw off-brand character universe
very good very nice drawing
thank you Sam your art so Harry
it's like Ed Edd n Eddy almost like you
have it I love that show that shaky line
that shaky light yet purposeful lines
were really cool oh man Wow yeah yours
is so far off I love it you know what I
got the hairs on the top of his head you
did okay yeah yeah you got the rest of
it dang he has no toes though he doesn't
man I got a way out
you got the shoe color correct that's
really good I know I got the pants color
wrong my face shape is different my
noses shape is the roll your nose is
down like Doug's nose I think you know
what that's for the one I got the most
wrong well very cool nice working with
you
you too is very charming and I wish you
nothing but the best in all you do thank
you see well thank you more than the
street out here in the BuzzFeed world is
that Jackie and Kevin are drawing my
characters now so if you'll excuse me
I'm gonna get over there and see what's
going on okay hey I get out of here okay
kids giveaway time if you want to enter
for a chance to win this welcome in to
us tablet all you have to do is go to
the BuzzFeed comics Instagram that's at
comics on Instagram find this post and
follow the instructions in the caption
best of luck to you
chair of justice huh I'm doing well you
drawing pictures this is Kevin's picture
this is Kevin this is bud this is Jack
these are very cute here let me show you
what the real Wanda looks like if you
guys be the judge
there's Wanda all right what do you
think well what do you got that we get
the hair swirl right she put highlights
in the eyes though she gave us a little
Walt Disney go it's a very Jackie
now Kevin has got a real this was the
style of seeing this is very Sanjay and
Craig okay have you seen Sanjay it's
cool to see another style so do you guys
there did you ever draw Fairly
OddParents before this is literally my
first time drawing drawing anything no
drawing for oh so butch while you're
here can you tell us a little bit about
the design style for The Fairly
OddParents as you were saying before
that's very kind of you PA inspired when
I first did this at Nickelodeon I
thought well I'll just do something I've
ever done before so I'll be honest with
you I sort of based it a little bit on
John Kriss pallucci style a little bit
but as the show went on I sort of
created a language like all the
characters have the same shape head I
love that design style of like yeah UPA
hanna-barbera back in the 60s if you
look at Wanda's hair it's like Wilma
Flintstone okay exactly and so yeah
everything comes from somewhere well
thank you for critiquing our drawings
yes we greatly appreciate it you're
welcome I will magically disappear out
of here no no it's fine you didn't
almost hit anything
hey I'm Kyra lead animator on the good
advice cup - oh yeah Mike character
animator on The Simpsons and today we
are gonna be drawing Simpsons characters
from memory fare you work on the Simpson
your character is sexy so glad because I
actually know who that is
feels like I'm wearing nothing at all oh
okay
he's like kind of one of the more normal
looking dudes isn't he yeah I feel like
he has like a weird like shark fin for a
hairdo
that's the main guy yeah the guy that
they based the Simpsons off of and we
better watch ourselves because we have
an animator from The Simpsons here
drawing with Kara
oh he's gonna look at her dying so he's
gonna cruelly and unjustly judge us his
Instagram handle is I draw Homer
so Mike you've been working on The
Simpsons since 2004 how did you get that
job I was actually an intern after high
school I just did you know a lot of
interns I'll work but slowly and slowly
I moved my way up to you know begging
artists for tips and like maybe I could
do with drawing and then one of their
scenes here and there
and I just like practicing and
practicing until one day I took the
character animation test and I passed it
that's so cool I didn't grow up watching
you didn't know I feel like everybody
grew up watching this and I kind of I
have vague memories of the Simpsons just
being on TV everywhere okay so like I'm
in the laundromat waiting for stuff to
do but I never actually watched it
myself really yeah let's see if I can
just manage doing the Simpson Sal that's
another thing I don't draw like that
most of the time I feel like most of my
stuff has like a lot of volume and
construction to it or is there sort of
exists very much in a 2d plane I think
you're more volumetric than the center
well is there specific kind of volume
volumetric um oh this is this is close
enough but it's not great you're scared
of the I love drawing homework I am
scared of the Mike's critique I'm not
gonna lie you're afraid of the animators
war army because which was he draws
Homer for a living like that's what he
does you know what we do for a living
what we are wrong for a living Internet
we draw incorrectly for living on the
internet we draw other people's
characters wrong so that people can
laugh at us hmm so honestly so honestly
we're doing our job right doing our job
if yeah if it's wrong you know yeah yeah
and a meme is hamburgers steamed hams oh
they're just their hands not hammers
it's hamburgers but he's like up selling
it as steamed hams because he has like
his boss over for dinner
Oh instead of like his meal goes to and
so he like runs across the street to get
hamburgers and it's like oh enjoy these
gourmet steamed hands so as an animator
on The Simpsons what's here like your
day-to-day routine look like so we have
scenes that we get from the board
artists and you know they set up the
shot they set up the composition our job
is to go in and add all the acting and
we get the audio track from the voice
actors and then we kind of go from there
I think we're like the last one that
actually does all that stuff everything
else like boards here's a fun fact about
Homer's design that I do know there is a
Hidden Mickey signature in his in his
head
it is his hair is an M and his ear looks
like a G from Matt Groening really
that's really interesting cool I will
make his ear G now G for gamer G M for
mega and G for gamer mega gamer no not
right at all he's just wearing like us
he's wearing a suit right yes okay the
principle suit principle a very
principle hey wait am I dressed are you
dressed like him Cody stand up give you
some reference and my dress video yeah i
Principal Skinner
Percival Skinner so Mike have you ever
met the voice actors from The Simpsons
uh yeah actually I went to a couple of
table reads which is you know they'd
you're like a little rough run through
the script you know all the actors are
there they're do their lives or their
voice is really awesome to see that's so
cool and they're extremely talented I
hear you're quite the voice actor
yourself yes I am Kevin what's your
favorite episode of The Simpsons so my
favorite episode of The Simpsons is
called Lisa's substitute it's an episode
in the second season where Lisa has a
very inspiring teacher who ends up going
away because he's a substitute teacher
yeah but he gives her the sweetest note
in the world uh-huh and tells her
look at it when you are starting to
doubt yourself and as he goes away she
opens it up and it says you are B system
but then my other favorite episode is
the one cute oh my god
okay that was so cute and that was just
the synopsis you know I didn't actually
I watched the episode should watch it oh
my god you guys like I'm a mess
it's okay sorry look at me deep breath
deep breath oh well didn't expect to cry
in the Simpsons episode Cody how do you
do dead accurate I mean this is
basically on model yeah are you applying
to Simpsons right now I'm probably gonna
submit this yeah print how did you do
you also think you're gonna get the job
I think I'm gonna shoo-in at this point
hmm yeah they're bringing me on tomorrow
that's confident how do you think you
did on this one I try drawing a little
more on my style but I think I did
pretty good
got pretty close to sexy planners how
about you yeah the feel of them down how
do you think you did Kevin I think I did
okay
so I feel like it's everything's just a
little bit off this Homer is part of the
off-brand character universe shown right
here I think I did pretty good just
about you know I I didn't really grow up
watching The Simpsons but I think I
understand the general look of Homer I
think I caught his essence I don't know
if it's accurate all right cool let's
take a look oh yes nice like I should
add a color no yours is so beautiful
it's like a perfect sketch this is
appealing I like this I would eat those
hamburgers thank you
oh my this is so it's pretty impression
istic you didn't go for the Simpsons
style this is very much a Cody version
of a Simpsons character I just wanted to
feel more nervous like he was nervous
about those steamed hands yeah because
that's all I remember is his anxiety yes
you did a pink donut which is the iconic
Simpsons donut yeah it's because I went
to the Universal Studios and they were
selling giant pink donut you know that's
like all I could think of I didn't I
didn't put the pink frosting yeah I love
his face
so good I like the shiny but you're
gonna feel a nice touch yeah I remember
there was a helmet oh man okay
see there's that perfect like rectangle
body I just like I did this at some
point you could probably see sketches
over there somewhere where I just was
like use the line tool just draw like a
straight line down yeah oh yeah no but
you did like you got so much right
really hard but we got the feel we got
that yeah look at this rear 3/4 on
Chalmers here yeah and bizarre like I I
got that he was bald
Wilmers guy oh yeah I don't know you
start drawing Chalmers I Drive I drew
that like Homer second yeah well thanks
a lot for having me of course it was so
nice to meet you I had an awesome time
drawing trying to draw it was awesome
but I hear that Kevin jakir drawing home
right all right so I'm gonna go check
them out I'll see you later
are you ready Kevin ready let's bring
and Mike yeah first try Mike how are you
good thanks for joining us so this is
Jackie's drawing of Homer okay you are
somebody who draws Homer for a living
yes how on or off model is Jackie strong
it's a beautiful drawing model but I
mean it's really appealing so if you had
to do one or two things to make this a
little more on model oh well definitely
so I would pick your dad he's getting in
he's gift he's grading me like a he
fixed your ear mine I like the G in
there though
it's mg mg for mega gamer yeah yeah yeah
it's been confirmed been confirmed on
screen do you want to take a look at my
shirt okay Mike come on over on I'm
nervous I'm very nervous don't be scared
Kevin all he'll do is say it's awful and
draw over to make it perfect Wow this is
like Homer Simpson meets George Jetson
okay so this is again
appealing oh here's the thing about the
muzzle how does
connect to his nose because I feel like
so it goes from the bottom line of those
okay and I need a trick about the ear
take the bottom line of eyeball it lands
really funny structures yeah he's like a
little too tall and uh no Anatomy the
arm just a gomez tubes it like yeah they
do have a rubber hose arms I did that
person it felt weird you know what Kevin
this is why you need to believe in
yourself check into believe you need to
trust your gut like Homer has a gut am i
right Mike that's right well Mike thank
you for critiquing our homers thank you
my you are full of magic
Mike this is why we can't have guests
Jackie that horrible to say totally yeah
we'll get out of here okay okay oh I'm
sorry I apologize for all that I've done
hey I'm raw strengths and needs channel
roughs all you can follow me on my
social at Ross Charles hello my name is
Anthony Jones you can follow me at robot
pencil and all that today we're drawing
Dragon Ball Z characters from memory
pretty much
I watched General Z one of the kid a lot
whenever I teach all I use is like
Dragon Ball our alliances yeah can we
switch sides now my decide once you just
like over there this has always been my
side I've no idea Oh someone else then
gotta get that side honky blueberry
Vegeta oh yeah okay I try to be
subversive and not have empowering up
you give Vegeta whatever attitude speaks
to you I'm gonna have a huffy Vegeta
oh wait isn't there like multiple go
cous which one are we drawing I think
we're just drawing the base grown up
Goku three majin buu was like one of my
favorite arcs in Dragon Ball Z I think I
stepped out of Dragon Ball Z during this
age he's got a very angular body angular
face much like my own head oh I got a
video reference right in front of me it
looks like so you never watched
racquetball I watched some dragon balls
but definitely not
enough to like to call myself a fan
through social osmosis I know quite a
lot about Dragon Ball Z I know that they
need to collect the Dragon Balls to make
their wish come true
wait are we sure this isn't pokemon no I
have no idea what he wears like we
communicate all right cool so I was
gonna give him my cape and I'm gonna
give him some muscle and he has pants
does he have a shirt on
oh I don't know am I in shirtless then
we're going for it yeah I haven't
watched Dragon Ball Z since college so
this is gonna be real interesting when
do you think I went to college Jackie
1753 the same age that Lincoln was born
what's your favorite Dragon Ball Z
episode oh man
maybe Dragon Ball Kai episode where they
assembled five episodes into one and
they removed all the panning shots of
like lakes and some like grass wrestling
in a few I have a lot of b-roll in that
fictional universe I think an antenna
there's a real stereotype of around
aliens and yeah from different worlds
that they all have antennas I feel like
we need to break that stereotype I know
he's wearing like an orange jumpsuit
right with a belt
form and function over fashion in this
show remind me why were they fighting
all the time cuz they're all fighting
over the Dragon Ball you don't catch
them all you got a catch mall unlike
other shows that might use that MA no I
don't want you to forget about Vegeta's
intense widow's peak oh yes thank you
that is the key to this character Vegeta
is what introduced me to what a widow's
peak was yeah he's really he's really
got it going when I was growing up I
watched a lot of Dragon Boat see how old
are you and you were drunk watching that
stuff I was like six seven eight it was
it was the thing I think what I loved
about Dragon Ball was that it was like
it was kind of like a soap opera for
children a soap opera for children does
he work gloves I feel like he wears some
butler gloves like white gloves yeah
when you're punching so many things
don't you have to protect your hands
doesn't like boxing gloves you're giving
boxy
she's a given boxing glove okay even
though I'm 99% sure he does not have
boxing look oh he has a thing I don't
know what it says doesn't you have a
logo on his shirt I'm just gonna draw a
circle with the heart in it oh let me
ask are you putting him in like the pink
shirt Bermuda shorts Vegeta or no
think about thinking about I was like I
want casual summer vacation but yeah
that's one of my favorite things about
Dragon bows the episodes is that they
would do these random so I mean it's not
my favorite it annoyed the hell out of
me as a kid but it's really funny
looking back that it would be like the
planets at stake and didn't you wonder
how like yeah sure Robi was getting his
driver's license no nobody yeah sure
Robi
this is a joke looks like how many
Dragon Ball Z characters does it take to
screw in a light bulb
I don't know only takes one but takes
five episodes to do it oh there's this
whole arc with Goku holding up a spear
bomb yeah and for like five six seven
episodes so I remember Dragon Ball Z
mostly from the Super Nintendo game
there's a Super Nintendo oh hell yeah
there was it like a fighting game yeah
it's like Street Fighter but it's mostly
just you throwing giant fireballs and
energy at each other that sounds great
yeah that's all I want to do in real
life
you just want to throw giant fireballs
at me yeah Jackie I remember he was
weirdly small in the show he's small but
he's also just like really thin and
delicate looking yeah I remember wasn't
super intimidated by him when I first
saw him because he was standing next to
like the big guys yeah that's the whole
ball big yeah supposed to be like a weak
looking prints but then he's the
strongest one Toriyama was good at that
kind of thing I like that if I was like
in the you know design room and they're
like Anthony what do you think we should
do with this character first of all
would be like he needs more muscles
muscles what and then they'll probably
would be rightfully angry and I'm
alright the next step we need to spread
that pink all over the place are you
gonna make him glow as I make them glow
I'm gonna make you a little boy cuz when
they do the screaming thing when they
scream at each other when they scream at
each other they glow don't they I think
so alright I will try to make him glow
what's his color scheme is he blue and
red moving hello well yeah he's like
yellow and the version I'm drawing could
use got you like saying I remember
oh my god I can't I can't remember his
colors I was so confident going in I'm
like oh I know he looks like he's just
like a big just know that my design is
inspired by your work so if I am wrong
everybody I'm not the blade whoa and
then if you're
I'm your n then you are do you think EE
when they're like juice enough to become
Super Saiyans when they're juice enough
you know what I mean you know what I'm
talking about Jackie don't pretend like
you don't know what I'm talking about
say Goku is juice enough don't like
rocks and stuff like float oh yeah
whenever they're juicing up stop saying
juice it up juicing up Jackie baby I
gave my guy black nipples back legs you
have nipples I think so I think so dude
Dragon Ball Z matured you they went
myths
nice oh I remember I think he has a
siblings forehead like m4 majin buu hey
Cody
Hey what does the scanner say about his
power level its over 9000 time to color
dodge ready that lighting in there oh
snap and now that are so good if it
looks better look at all that good stuff
is getting out of the thief the kite no
check it out that's the secret to art
that is the secret art just color dodge
everything that's all you need you can
add that color dodge you didn't get to
draw the glow Kevin you didn't get to
draw the glow I didn't get to draw the
glow
what happened I passed out in the middle
of the video for some reason I didn't
notice any of that yeah I you were
really into I was really into my boy no
it's okay I'm fine okay I might die in
us up in a couple seconds okay how do
you think you did mm Jack you know i'ma
call mine okay cool
how do you think you did I think it
captures the essence pretty well I'm
missing a lot of details I forgot to put
sandals on them it's another
impressionistic one I'm here for it how
did you do pretty good pretty close
Vegeta with some Brent flair in there I
feel good about the blue spandex I feel
good about the yellow armor pieces but
there's just little naggy things that
feel off that I just can't figure out
right now how do you think you did I
think I did pretty okay his hair is
blond because he was yelling okay but I
think it is black normally yes yes I
didn't get rude all the glow so now it
just you know looks like crap I'm sure
it doesn't look like crap looks like
crap Jackie throw it in the crap settle
down can I say crap sure looks like crap
whoa so cool this is way more cute this
is the personality look cake I should
have added cake yeah dude come on this
stuff is great oh my god this is that
looks just like him you gave him elf
ears for sonic in Bell fears yeah it's
not what did the kind of years he has I
don't think so I know he is he wait
oh I'm just now remembering they're like
aliens right okay looks like a zombie
version a moderator I think so too well
you know in a really good way no this is
amazing actually
I was expecting you were gonna make your
character really adorable you know what
a good anime face really yeah and you
know what else I'm gonna say it looks
nothing like Kevin it does not look like
Kevin at all
I like the boxing gloves I think that he
should have boxing gloves normally so
his hip flat things also protect his
junk he's just got a full like beetle
wings protecting his whole area yeah
okay so I kind of got there was a beetle
that's it a beetle wing I kind of got
that on his belly
protecting his abdomen but you got to
protect the crotch I blame Ross with him
you didn't give me anything I was like
he had he had this yet back yet an
antenna yeah we're really off are we
Dragon Ball Z fans nice all right all
right looks good looks good
the thing about his spiky hair I knew it
wasn't spiky all the way I knew that
yeah I knew it we got like a like a
thick yeah it's like designed
purposefully in a really cool way that's
got to be hell to animate though because
it's very specific yeah I'm glad we
didn't do it me watching this as a kid I
haven't seen this character for over two
decades and so the things you do
remember at the kid components of good
design yeah the pink
I remember the M and it means that the
designer probably put that in there for
us to remember it and so two decades
later we're gonna Busby John majin buu
so now that's a great point absolutely I
personally didn't grow up with it but it
impacted a whole generation of people
they really did it's like pokemons it's
so popular that even I know majin buu
and I think majin buu is very cute I
don't know who majin buu is character
animator on The Simpsons
hey young Kira lead animator on good
advice cupcake today we are drawing
Justice League characters from memory
from memory Wow Justice League yeah I
think I love them do you know who the
Justice League are you sound very
confident all right give us the
characters the flash was my favorite
sources yeah your answer today is
underwater I feel like that's manageable
I'm trying to picture in my head
Superman okay it's like the worst one
that was who is your favorite Justice
League character of holy Batman Batman
is too angsty and Superman is too
serious and he's a real boy what the
flash is just right I like bumbling
buffets you really do I like the dumb
one that's your type I had no idea that
you were a flash fan I really thought
that you were gonna be like what what do
you know about the flash I know that his
superpower is SuperSpeed I know that his
name is Barry Allen yeah Superman is a
man that is super very powerful laser
eyes x-ray vision there isn't a thing
that you can't do I know vague
generalities yeah DC characters but I
don't you know I don't know much I
remember I read one of the flash comics
and I was surprised to learn he doesn't
only go fast but he also can learn fast
that's cool I guess isn't that wild and
wacky stop saying bother Viking isn't
that wild and wacky with Barry Allen as
my Cintiq turned off your Cintiq how do
I turn it back on
superheroes are hard to draw so what do
you usually start with Mitra I'll
usually try to start with the line of
action what
kind of axes like the character spine
for the pose it's like a guideline for
how the pose will lay mines different
every single time yeah I'll start with
the body
one day I'll start with a head one day I
even started with the hand one time
that's a good job I love dry hands
people are such a weak they're always
like I hate drying hands shut up they're
fun to blends up here yeah it's up here
it's over here on your side did I do I
always draw like 16 fingers on one hand
people are like did you notice did you
know there's 16 fingers on the hand
instead of 5 I'm like why would I draw
16 fingers on accident are you crazy
I like how they ask you that question as
if you like close your eyes and two
hands like whoops
fix it fix it fix it listen fix it fix
it fix it fix it fix it oh I fixed it
that was cool it's a good thing I was I
thought quick on the fly like flash what
you know what I don't like this I don't
like what I'm going you're restarting
I'm restarting I'm gonna draw a cute
flesh I'm sorry this is just how it has
to be I got the pose now I just got to
do the details and I don't know the
details of his suit I know that you know
you can't really see his eyes right
right he's got kind of a Batman mask yes
he has the thing where his eye mask
moves with his emotion right which is
weird that doesn't happen that her style
of dress is kind of I think it's like
kind of yeah I know he's got tiny
squinty thang tiny tiny eyes big angular
jaw curly hair I just know that it's red
yeah but there's nothing else in my head
right now yeah I know that he has the
you know headphone things I got that
does he have a belt like a waist band
maybe oh man whatever she's legit she's
I'm a shield busy I hope Thanks
she has like her her dog lives right
right on a rope in the road oh I did
watch the live-action 90s flash show oh
how did that work out it was actually
that bad for the first season and then
it got terrible oh but that flash for
some reason I know that he has a belt
okay flash symbol on it was a rope
called again as me lasso of truth does
he have a flash like a lightning symbol
on his I think so on his chest I think
he does because they sell flash shirts
all right how are you doing Johnny I am
having a hard time however I like what's
happening to mine yeah it's not that
great but it's like there should be low
expectations for me as all I'm saying
everyone's a critic
everyone's a critic do you have a
favorite comic book hero movie really
like Deadpool simple yeah I feel like
that may be the reason why I hate
Superman and like Batman and all those
people's cuz like I would be one of the
villains like I feel like I really like
fit into that category and how I act
generally the villains are
anti-establishment sure yeah and I'm
always like tweeting about how I hate
Amazon yeah it's the same it is the
Joker burning things down and me
tweeting about how I hate Amazon are
like the same thing that's disconcerting
okay I gave them way too much crotch I
don't know I think I'm struggling to
remember this costume I honestly don't
remember anything about the costume kind
of winging it and I think there's a wrd
huh yeah right it's like she has a sword
- I have no idea that looks like yeah
alright my flash is looking cute there's
a lot of flashes so who can really say
this is accurate my drawing kind of
looks like if a super villain was trying
to draw Superman like trying to make fun
of him kinda I think I'm just
straight-up a villain from DC but I love
this idea of method drawing embody the
character I decided not to commit to
color so I'm just gonna add like tones
sometimes color just like makes or
breaks it yeah are the core switched
maybe they're switched you know I don't
really know what his symbols colors are
but I'm gonna go with white and yellow
yeah it seemed seems correct he's kind
of looking more like a McDonald's
character right now then uh then a
Justice League character I apologize to
Barry Allen and his son Wally West oh
wait is this son no no I think I'm done
here I think I'm done okay okay
I drew a handsome man because apparently
even if you're from space you just
handsome
okay now I need to do like a speed
effect real quick here's what I'm gonna
do I'm done I'm gonna take the whole
thing I'm gonna pretend like I'm fine
okay - I am going to do a directional
blur hey remember the thing you can do
to make it look like your pencil is
wobbly yeah we get it Jackie you finish
before I did I'm trying to entertain
them done you done Kevin done with my
flash finished it in a flash so I'm like
how do you think you did I wasn't sure
about her costume I don't know if it's a
two-piece if it's a one-piece how about
you I feel like I I remembered some of
the stuff about like the central costume
but colors it looks like a Halloween
store like discount cost hey Jen how'd
you do I did okay I just purr man in
transition from the mild-mannered man
becoming Superman mine is very plain mmm
I am gonna warn you though there's a lot
of crotch coming our way and at the cry
there's a lot of crotch come on guys so
he's just gonna have to deal with it he
was gonna deal with Flash's groin and
his crotch his costume is so simple that
there's no way to mask is going I mean
there is but you know Kevin I'm just
gonna let it slide this time because I
don't want to hear you say crotch again
I'm just letting you know
Lana crotch all right let's switch
oh wow this looks so good oh gosh you
made it look incredible you actually had
a full color this looks like a finished
awesome drawing here I love the style
yours has such a great pose like it's
like that Fibonacci spiral around like
pleasing to look at
yes oh this is yes I love this Superman
your dreams are cute you too I love it I
think that like you just like kind of
drew him you know you really overplayed
the crutch way you described it I was
thinking you gave him like a basketball
in there it's really not that bad very
spiky lightning bolt mm-hmm yeah yeah I
think I put too many spikes on I think
it's going the wrong way I think you got
it the right way
I don't you never know oh oh yeah you
got it oh she's just wearing like a
bathing suit
yeah I guess I was remembering the movie
too much yeah I don't know why but for
some reason we thought she had a WN or
two I forgot the stars
yes stars there he is
yeah you literally just drew him like
when I said that earlier like I meant it
it was like he literally just did it
Johnny captured the inner essence of
Superman because there's a cost of being
super at all at all times does it cost
what Wow no no no this isn't the flash I
know Wow he's got full-on yellow boots
yeah ascott you know what it's not fair
to judge our flash off of one flash
drawing because there's certain creation
there's many class so many costume
changes he goes through maybe this is
casual day flash it's hard to get those
little details but the broad idea I
think I think we think we got it close
enough close enough flash is a cool guy
flash is a cool guy he's a chill guy uh
cool superpower
I wish I was fast so do I yeah I'm real
slow I'm real slow when it comes to
drawing I'm real slow when it comes to
thinking am i right ladies to brain
cells hands up
that's millennial talk for you what does
that mean
hi I'm hit Ewan I'm Joanie and today
we're gonna be drawing my neck hurts
it's not today we're going to draw the
Marvel superheroes from memory didn't we
already do that we did DC I don't know
we did Justice League whatever universe
is straight whatever they're all the
same guy this is right up your
wheelhouse I hope so I'm like man do not
mess this one up because I've read so
many marvel comics let me tell you and
when you're making up a lot of stuff but
first be sure to stick around to the end
of the video to find out how you can
enter for a chance to win this Wacom
Intuos tablet courtesy of our good
friends and welcome I'm not wearing
shoes not relevant that's the best one
he's the best I do love spider-man
fighter verse is the best movie ever
created it's really good Myles that
Spiderman love Gwen Stefani loved Peter
Parker Peter B Parker these are sea
Parker's not going Stefani Judy Park
when Stacy
Peter can think of as a head thing oh
yeah the head thing that goes up like
that yeah all right let's see don't mess
this up Jason don't mess this up what do
you think I'm telling myself Captain
Marvel hip cool I don't know who this is
like actually so I'm just gonna try man
okay like a person I'm falling alright
I'm gonna try my best to do a dynamic
spider PO me too oh my god can you give
us three hours in the comics he was made
to be like short and muscular
oh he's short in the yeah so which was
weird why they chose Hugh Jackman to
play him because he's supposed to be
like five feet tall or something like
that oh okay Hugh Jackman's like what
six four is he oh is he really yeah you
Jackie's like really tall if you're
showing any skin he's very hairy yes I
remember that he's got the hairiest like
arms the shape of stars or intricate
integrated into the costumes I think
there's
a star on the belt buckle it feels like
you're trying to like help me remember
but the thing is I don't know who this
here I'm sending you an image of a
little lady a lady with blond hair okay
oh yeah see it won't have it back in the
90s spider-man was having a renaissance
with a comic book artist by the name of
Todd McFarlane because he came along and
drew spider-man in a way that no one
else had before what different ways can
you draw a spider he did what was called
spaghetti webs where spider-man's webs
didn't look like webs they look like
strands of spaghetti like kind of like
wrapped around each other oh yeah so he
was kind of a pioneer in terms of that
he also made the eyes on the mask bigger
than they've ever been and he also was
the character designer for venom if your
favorite superhero is venom you're
either a really edgy 13 year old boy or
a 25 year old woman that just got out of
a long relationship another thing in the
90s everyone had his shoulder pads oh
okay thank you
were they pointy they weren't like
pointy they kind of went up like this
like they just kind of went out and went
in like that okay good I did not draw
that I think for the suit on drawing his
arms were sleeveless and then we had the
gloves
I appreciate the less clothing I have to
draw the better can Masumi she has boots
yes I think I think those are correct
assumptions but also I don't know the
character very well so I'm just gonna
probably say yes to most of the things
she said yeah I think she I don't know
show some cape I don't know I'm sorry
Marvel fans who was your favorite
spider-man from spider-verse miles he
was well written you know he went from
like not really being sure of himself
but then he met Quinn Stefani and then
he Mick when Stefani and she said I'm
gonna add a bunch of unnecessary details
to destroy I want to add a helmet but
I'm afraid it's gonna make her like
Cyclops oh my god what scent it doesn't
make sense to me but I don't have
context for it like I know I keep saying
it just that it's true
you know my favorite spider-man from
spider-verse was Peter be Parker do you
want
why is it cuz your old nose because he
was a nod to the spider-man that I grew
up with a lot of the jokes in the
beginning when he's like retelling his
story and everything like that those
were all jokes about the continuity of
the spider-man that I grew up with
pretty cool you have no idea what I just
said yeah I was looking at my dry ok so
what is this basic costume it's really
simple sometimes people draw claw marks
on his torso okay like he's cut himself
or like he will cut you yeah yeah it's
his design that's kind of stayed very
similar over the years give him like the
superhero Underpants I know he probably
doesn't have it he doesn't well you know
what
that's how I imagine him what I'm slowly
realizing is that it appears that I've
drunk I've drawn one of the Hanson
brothers really slowly realize I mean
I'm sure there is a crossover I'm sure
of the finger of the fan fandoms
he's as yellow and black right yellow
and black or yellow and blue or yellow
and brown yellow has always been a
mainstay in his costume I know like
maybe vaguely visually what some of them
look like like the Avengers maybe like
just from seeing posters or something I
just like don't watch any of them it's
actually kind of impressive how was it
impressive I went a dark yard but it's
like you have to spend money to go see
them like that means I'm just like sick
not you know that means you're being
financially responsible yeah I can't
think of anything he's got he's got skin
there I'm taking this hairy body thing
and I'm running with it I'm excited to
see what you're gonna do I think you'll
be surprised oh my god I just realized I
did not draw his other hand
yeah I'm just gonna beef this hand huh
you're gonna be fish just gonna beef
this hand I knew it I knew that would
catch on you know what he's gonna be
like flicking you off with his claws
perfect he's got to you know we've got
302 he's got attitude Oh - that's it - I
don't know if anyone's ever flicked to
someone off with his claws before well
he does he does the thing where he puts
up just the middle one okay yeah I did
it the other two are bending down at
first they didn't wanna makes my
because they were like oh nobody likes
spiders I think this is gonna be gross
that was a Stan Lee's story behind it
and he was like I'll show them
I'll make him the most popular superhero
in the world yeah for some reason he's
been old his whole life in this scenario
he's already like oh yeah Jason how you
doing I'm like struggling with us
stretch man I'm like struggling the
finish and to like save my reputation as
someone who likes like the comic oh my
god it's no pressure but like if I
screwed up a spongebob meme that would
be my devastation hey I actually really
liked my drawing I did like I'm pretty
proud of it it's just that like it's
probably not what it the character is at
all but like I like it I like the
drawing and that's what's most important
its most important is loving yourself
it's true how do you think you did Brett
oh man you're gonna be real impressed
no I didn't Jason how do you think you
did buddy
this is 100% Wolverine how do you feel
about the drawing you did I love it I'm
really proud of it not anything like
what you want it to be though
it's a it's an art piece that I'm gonna
sell for a million dollars look for it
on Etsy yeah how do you think you did it
looks okay you know it doesn't look
polished doesn't even really look right
but it does look like spider-man how do
you think you did I think I did okay Wow
I did my best low-budget todd mcfarlane
style todd mcfarlane
style spider-man Rider man yeah yeah he
would be very upset if he saw this and
if he saw this yeah yeah but it's
definitely spider-man it's definitely
stop doing that yeah all right
switcheroo switcheroo buckaroo I was
gonna say curse words
[Music]
yes yes here that is amazing I like
yours how that gives - thank you also to
me
yeah Wow I didn't I wasn't that
thoughtful I'm so sorry
well can't draw me in here yeah you sure
yeah Wow Wow okay okay you always
surprise me feel like it's when you're
the most hard on yourself that you come
at me with these like really accurate
dry looks yeah you got the costume way
more correct than me I'm think you know
what I think I did but your pose is
super dynamic and super fun Thanks and I
love the speed lines thank you and you
kind of did the spaghetti style webs
yeah I guess I like those yeah they go
like this flip flip flip flip I did
pretty good
oh well yours looks like similar like
it's a full body suit actually see I
knew she had a mask on but and in her
hair comes out of it I like this
character design of this of this woman
it's very appealing appealing designs I
forget that she has two belts like a
cool person cool okay actually the head
thing not so off your I mean you got the
shape yeah heard of the shape and is
that these like specific claw marks on
his on his torso that's like a some like
little black claws so this is from the
cartoon and I shouldn't remember that oh
and he's got the underwear yeah god I I
led you astray with that no man I'm
sorry I let you in feeling better yeah
okay
so I also screwed up the blue yeah but
you got close I got closer but I forgot
that he has blue on his side's his
abdomen well like there's a bunch of
spider-man's again which one are we
remembering the classic I mean but even
the classics have classics spider-man's
been around for a long time this is true
but this is the original costume is it
really yeah no yeah no yeah no spiders
existed before spider-man and spiders
aren't red or blue traditionally
as far as I know anyway alright giveaway
time if you want to enter for a chance
to win this Wacom Intuos tablet all you
have to do is go to BuzzFeed comics on
Instagram that's at comics on Instagram
find this post and follow the
instructions in the description that's
the look if your post Malone do not
enter this giveaway what why what do you
have against post Malone I don't know I
love all I can buy his own hey I'm Ross
Tran from the YouTube channel rough gel
you can see my art at Ross Ross hi my
name is Anthony Jones and you can follow
me at robot pencil and today we're gonna
be drawing characters from memory I mean
I grew up with Nintendo's like my first
like video game series you know I think
my first game that I played probably
ocarina of time like that's my dad
playing at first and then I started to
play it yeah Nintendo was like my first
exposure to video games yeah I feel like
not everybody just jumps online I'm
excited
are you excited I love Nintendo I'm a
Nintendo fan girl like I grew up on
Nintendo games I still played Nintendo
games you don't have a Nintendo switch
that's totally fine I respect your
opinion
well because everyone can afford I was
about to go real south and real soon but
I 1000 games are great and if you have
the excess funds to purchase one I
highly recommend it I don't have a
switch you're different I hate you
already be sure to stick around to the
end of the video to find out how you can
enter for a chance to win this Wacom
Intuos s tablet courtesy of our friends
at welcome Kevin made me sign it
everyone's gonna sign it but Kevin made
music I didn't make you do anything are
you just gonna do voices this entire
episode yeah it's a B Mario is that he's
are my friend
Yoshi oh that's Pikachu that's a really
good withdraw Jackie oh yes that's
awesome dude it's right up your alley
and it's a girl hydro robots we both
have something in that I know the
general colors we got like red and gold
to bring helmet is it a green element
really I'm pretty sure because I'm drawn
salmon hold on hold on listen I'm John
Salmons two times in the past year so
I'm back but would her if I were a green
Honda we're talking about Oh G oh my god
okay so evil mario evil I have a friend
named Jackie who loves Yoshi it's not me
I promise it's not like a joke
Jackie files if you're out there this
one's for you did you ever play any of
the like WarioWare games and I love
Wario air yeah it's so much fun no Aria
is a really good character him in
waluigi mm-hmm I love them yeah I don't
think I've ever drawn them before so
Yoshi is a dinosaur he comes from like a
dinosaur egg he comes from Yoshi's
Island dinosaur island Jurassic Park
welcome to Yoshi's Island Samus is one
of my favorite characters no really I
think it's because she was like one of
the very first like female characters
like that twist at the end
and just one character that's going
through this crazy dungeon fighting all
these aliens and it comes to find out
it's a female protagonist which is cool
my Yoshi is starting to look like a
horse like my horse yeah how did you do
that because like he's he has to have
like a dip in his back for Mario to sit
on right he doesn't have to look like a
horse
yeah so this is a technique that I do to
look at the drawing from another fresh
perspective I do this a lot in my
professional work it's just to kind of
see all mistakes that I know I'm we
don't see it's like looking into a
mirror or reflecting yourself and seeing
like a different kind of perception so
I'm changing my perception a lot when I
flipped my canvas to get a fresh take on
what I'm doing Steph what's your
favorite Nintendo game that's a big
question
I love the Zelda series overall and I
think I always kind of go back and forth
between what my favorites are but it
almost always lands on Wind Waker I
think it's like aesthetically a really
gorgeous game it's beautiful yeah what
is your favorite I love animal cross you
know I'm really good at doing toad okay
give me some of your toad right give me
your best Mario
how do you think you're doing so far
definitely not on model I feel like it's
essence of Wario more than it is Wario
which Spurs of what yeah this isn't too
far from what I actually do like I
worked on a cinematic called Rose for
StarCraft yeah legacy of the void
cinematic a lot of the characters there
were designed by me it was essentially
like this like like here's a character
design of our game but we just want to
like level it up a little bit yeah you
know or just like modernize it and
that's kind of like what I'm trying to
do with this Samus character I'm trying
to make it feel like oh yeah that's what
I do ro wouldn't make this Yoshi cute
but he looks dumb and I don't know how
to fix it oh I have no idea how to fix
mine I'm gonna be fit I'm gonna be fit
on purpose you're gonna what I'm gonna
be fit on purpose let us be fit me and
Jackie cuz I have a definition of what
be fit means you don't know what be fit
means I mean means you made a mistake
right also when I was growing up though
be fit meant to fart let's be fit with
Kevin's WG like I like Ross a lot
because his channel is very popular in
is his whole energy is just like art is
fun artists come in we can do we're
living and I think that's really
powerful and that's why I like this too
is like an I know there's gonna be some
kid out there watching this draw
watching all the other people draw and
you're like wait what I can do this we
can live in AI feel the bromance thank
you he doesn't have ears he's a dinosaur
oh wait he doesn't have ears I don't
think so I gave him ears I don't think
he has yours bro I want to give him
mirrors no come on I'm sticking with the
ears
what kind of ears did you even give you
look man I guess they're kind of
cat-like Oh Jackie Kevin I'm beefing it
stop saying beefing it smell so bad
smell so bad guys I'm beefing I'm
starting to question this green helmet
stuff now hold on I figure it out it's
it's this part oh yeah I can see ya know
that see yeah I know just a little bit
of tough to hit I don't know I think his
hat covers most of it
well he has bangs now he has a saddle
right I think he is a shell oh no really
what is Mario sit on the shell part I
don't think he why are you drawing a
horse
I think I'm drawing a horse Jackie I
think you're thinking of a great work I
think I'm a great force
have you read the fan theories that like
all the Mario games are an elaborate
stage play no yeah there's just kind of
this theory that all the games that you
play are are just performances by all
the characters and so that's why
sometimes they're all playing and being
friends and sometimes they're all
archenemy well that's cute and wholesome
yeah what time is it color done it's
color dodge time let's do it okay here
we go man I'm like coloring everywhere
he already got so sweet it tastes so
good the color dad you're having the
time your life with her I'm jealous a
flare now this is way better than the
other one I think Steph how do you think
you did I feel like he's a little too
Mario like I wasn't able to pull him
into the Wario Realm
how did you're worried I turn out he
turned out better than I thought he was
going to um yeah I think he could be
grosser how well did you think you did I
think I did great yeah yeah I I don't
think that I got the details right I'm
almost certain I'm a hugger so if
someone were to pass by this
oh is it the version of samus yes for
sure yeah how do you think you did not
correct me me there's not I don't it's
not correct we beefed it we beefed it it
is so smelly in here there is so much
ranked air yeah I'm basically breathing
another person's bowels I think we
should just switch
we got a Nintendo switch yeah you made
your kit your Samus is super around oh
is it
you got him though you like got his his
being thank you I forgot as the ears are
pointed dude you got like that the nose
and the mustache oh so we like
remembered the outfit pretty somewhere
we did yeah pocket which I hope he has
watch she's not gonna have it you're
definitely a lot closer than me it felt
right when I was working on the sketch
and you're right now that it's done
we're all geniuses in hindsight Jackie I
don't understand also you gave him
cowboy boots so well does it look as
wrong as giving Yoshi completely new
rims
maybe Yoshi has lots of different shoes
well he doesn't have cowboy boots I know
that just give us yeah oh my god with
gold shoulders it's it's the green Canon
the Kenny yeah the Canon is a different
color this I helped you with that green
helmet
no this is copy for copy you cheated
there's so much more I think I could
have done I still had a lot of fun I
didn't I think I'm inspired by looking
at this I'm like oh man I'm inspired by
my friend that's amazing here's why I
gave him ears because his eyes going up
like that made me think ears wrong yeah
it got switched in my brain I will say
Kevin body's pretty good really I think
my body is like the thing that makes him
look like a horse what's those shoes why
do we remember like brown shoes we got
pretty close to it we got something yeah
we're Wario Jason bring out the Smash
Brothers version I'm sure there's
pockets you know what Nintendo I love
your games and I love you and I'll keep
playing your games until I die even
after the horrible experience that we
just went through I will still preorder
all your games send me a switch Thank
You eNOS will you switch
all right giveaway time so if you want
to enter for a chance to win this Wacom
Intuos tablet all you have to do is go
to BuzzFeed comics on Instagram that's
at comics on Instagram look for this
post and follow the instructions in the
description best of luck to you best
look to you that's creepy no it's lovely
and I get lovelier every day
[Music]